ce qu'on découvre donc c'est qu'il est
très près de ses sous et il est
maléfique
votre grand-père
bonsoir vous publiez chez de Noël un
livre qui s'appelle grand-père et c'est
un titre qui n'est pas complètement
innocent puisque Pablo Picasso refusait
qu'on l'appelle grand-père donc tout le
monde avait l'appeler Pablo et même
votre père qui était son fils unique
voilà alors grand-père c'est l'histoire
de Picasso vu à travers les yeux de sa
petite fille vous Marina Picasso ce nom
Picasso dont vous dites le porter comme
on porte une croix
j'en avais pas la force psychologique et
puis parce que maintenant c'était le
moment de le faire c'est un moment de sa
vie où on peut faire un bilan avec un
certain recul et rester à ses objectifs
alors vous dites j'aurais pu devenir
alcoolique ou droguer il m'a fallu un
long travail thérapeutique aujourd'hui
vous avez 50 ans mais vous avez été en
analyse de l'âge de 30 ans à l'âge de 44
ans c'est à dire 14 ans d'analyse donc
pour arriver justement à récupérer par
rapport à l'enfance que vous avez eu
14 ans à revivre ce qui m'a détruit pour
me reconstruire alors bon Picasso on va
rappeler un peu voilà parce qu'il est
beaucoup de femmes donc on va essayer
quand même de rappeler avant de vous
interviewer
donc Picasso donc est à Paris évidemment
quand il rencontre votre grand-mère Olga
kohlova qui est la fille d'un colonel
russe qui a 10 ans de moins que lui qui
a un visage de madone et Diaguilev chez
qui elle dansait elle était dans les
balais Jake il lui dit fais gaffe une
Russe on l'épouse il l'épouse et il
divorcera jamais en fait toute sa vie
Picasso était mariée avec votre
grand-mère Olga c'est ça alors il a un
enfant Polo qui est donc votre père
mais si divorce pas il trompe très
rapidement votre grand-mère avec
Marie-Thérèse Walter blonde regard
gris-bleu 17 ans et puis après il y a
dorama il y a Françoise Gillot qui est
la mère de Paloma qu'on connaît ensuite
il y a Jacqueline rock enfin voilà donc
il y a eu beaucoup de femmes dans sa vie
alors ce qu'il faut savoir
Picasso je savais pas à ce point là et
d'une pingrerie hors du commun oui je
crois qu'on a eu un parcours
affectif et matériel extrêmement
difficile et oui par exemple il est très
sûr de lui il sait qu'il peut gagner de
l'argent très facilement il dit le vrai
prix de mes tableaux s'il était connu
personne voudrait le payer donc c'est
très bien comme il veut quand il voit un
jour il y a un de ces marchands qui lui
amène un nouveau billet de 500 francs il
voit le rond blanc au milieu du billet
de 500 francs il dessine une petite
corrida il dit voilà maintenant ça vaut
le double donc il sait très bien quand
il va dans un restaurant il fait un
dessin sur l'addition il paye pas alors
évidemment quand on est en France ça
surprend comme ça de pouvoir créer de la
monnaie d'une certaine façon difficile
de se structurer avec de telles de
telles images ce qu'on découvre donc
c'est qu'il est très près de ses sous et
il est maléfique
pas de grand-père schéma un peu rapide
mais c'est ça maléfique vous dites
d'ailleurs mon propos n'est pas de dire
du mal de Picasso mais de rendre
palpable la souffrance des victimes
victimes d'un virus un virus un peu
comparable au fameux virus I Love You
qui a été déchaîné à l'aube de l'an 2000
vous êtes Picasso à saccager notre
famille
oui oui c'est quand je retrace un petit
peu le
portrait et le parcours de mon père et
de ses petits-enfants en l'occurrence
mon frère et moi-même alors votre frère
Pablito se suicide de deux jours après
la mort de Picasso polo votre père il
devient alcoolique qui meurt d'un cancer
du foie à l'âge de 54 ans voilà et puis
en 1977 Marie-Thérèse Walter se pend
dans son garage en 85 Jacqueline Roch se
tire une balle dans la tête enfin c'est
quelqu'un qui a qui a produit comme ça
du malheur autour de lui et vous avez
été une de ces victimes d'une certaine
façon je suis déjà sa petite fille donc
je quitte sa famille mais bon là vous
prenez un petit peu des raccourcis mais
je crois que c'était un petit peu le le
prix à payer quand on a génie dans sa
famille il faut pas penser que tout se
passe très bien et sur un plan
artistique peut-être mais sur le plan
des relations de familiales c'est
différent
c'est ce que j'ai constaté c'est une
réalité mais est-ce que l'oeuvre mérite
autant de sacrifices humains
je pense que non non je pense qu'avant
même d'être un grand artiste souhaite
humain il faut avoir de la sensibilité
il faut voir ce qui se passe autour de
soi c'est incroyable dans cette histoire
quand on lit le bouquin qui est
passionnant c'est que Picasso qui a fait
Guernica qui a quand même fait qui était
communiste qui s'est battu pour la paix
aujourd'hui en France je sais pas il y a
combien de lycées de collège qui
s'appelle Picasso bon et en fait quand
on lit votre bouquin c'est un petit peu
terrible oui mais ça c'est le regard
d'un enfant de sa famille qui qui relate
sa vie qui ne dit pas du mal de son
grand-père mais qui relate ce qu'elle a
vécu alors dans le livre vous parlez de
votre grand-mère donc de votre père de
votre mère de votre frère alors votre
grand-mère souvent maltraité par les
biographes et vous vous essayez de la
réhabiliter d'une certaine façon
parce que je suis sa petite fille je
crois que je suis la seule au jour
d'aujourd'hui qui peut le faire parce
que je suis sa seule petite fille pour
lui pour votre pour votre grand-père
Olga avait abandonné son pays ses rêves
sa carrière et ben malgré tout elle
mourra paralysé pas très loin de chez
lui et il ira jamais la voir
maintenant pas ça votre père c'est
terrible votre père polo donc quand il
était petit c'est un petit Dieu quand il
était enfant et bien un jour il a
commencé à l'ignorer un petit peu sa
peinture il est représenté dans beaucoup
de de scènes tableau polo en arlequin
polo avec l'âne des portraits
extrêmement tendres et tout donc coup on
s'aperçoit qu'il n'est plus représenté
vous avez jamais été représenté
homard des crevettes plein de trucs mais
pas ses petits-enfants ses
petits-enfants légitimes oui j'aime pas
dire ça parce qu'on a l'impression qu'on
fait une différence mais c'est vrai nous
sommes les enfants de son fils aîné et
on n'a jamais été peint
alors bon ben votre père donc Paulo
c'était un petit peu le factotum le
souffre-douleur de Pablo Picasso il a
acheté ses cadres vis-à-vis des petits
boulots quoi c'est un peu son esclave
non
parce que c'est vrai et puis d'une
certaine façon mon père aimait beaucoup
son grand-père et je crois que c'est la
relation affective qui l'a fait rester
très proche de son père et ses la raison
pour laquelle il n'a pas voulu prendre
son indépendance
rebeller ou tout au moins aller vivre
ailleurs vous savez quand on est le fils
d'un grand artiste on n'a pas beaucoup
d'existence donc on fait ce qu'on peut
et on se sent tout petit vous voulez
dire qu'on est aimanté par le génie oui
il était même figé il était
l'application lui remettait l'argent au
compte-goutte il obligé à venir mendier
l'argent chez lui une certaine façon
c'est à dire qui était entretenu par son
père donc il n'avait pas d'indépendance
pécuniaire donc il devait passer par ses
caprices pour vivre convenablement oui
donc comme je l'ai dit alcoolique cancer
du foie alors votre mère elle portait le
nom de Picasso qu'on m'apporte une
médaille et alors elle avait épousé un
Picasso elle comprenait pas pourquoi
elle est pas une vie meilleure d'une
certaine façon oui je pense que au
départ elle était déçue de voir que ce
couple ne marchait pas et ensuite elle a
essayé de donner un sens à son histoire
et la tout projeter sur mon grand-père
et là elle s'est trompé d'hommes je
crois alors vos parents donc votre mère
est million et votre père Paulo divorce
quand vous avez six mois et pasblito
votre frère a deux ans et votre mère
finit par faire des ménages quand même
c'est vrai qu'elle mettait des barrières
et on n'était pas reçu spontanément et
c'était souvent très difficile alors
Jacqueline dit le soleil ne veut pas
qu'on le dérange
elle surnommait mon grand-père le soleil
le Dieu bon parce qu'elle le prenait
pour
j'allais dire pour quelque chose pour
quelqu'un de surhumain donc c'était
qualificatifs et
l'admirait tant qu'elle le traitait de
la sorte alors quand vous êtes admis à
rentrer parce qu'il y a des jours quand
vous pouvez rentrer l'humiliation est
pas moindre on peut dire d'une certaine
façon parce que lui vous reçoit en slip
c'est comme ça quoi c'est je crois qu'il
était
de façon
naturellement et alors ce qui est
terrible c'est kasméralda la chèvre elle
a le droit de faire ses cornes elle me
donne des petits coups de cornes comme
ça dans les meubles elle fait des
crottes sur les toiles enfin elle c'est
que vous vous avez droit à rien
et la chèvre à droite tout oui cet
exemple parce que c'est vrai que l'image
de la chèvre avait le droit de vivre en
liberté dans ses propriétés et nous on
avait tellement de barrières pour
accéder à notre grand-père que quand
j'étais petite je me réfugiais vers la
chèvre et je me dis elle elle a vraiment
de la chance et je rêvais d'être une
chèvre
alors il est très méchant très méchant
avec son fils dans votre père il dit tu
es médiocre tu me fais perdre mon temps
enfin
l'humilie
et il manquait vraiment de compassion
pour la race humaine
surtout pour son fils
il allait bouffer jusqu'à 3h du matin
quand même il avait beaucoup d'amis ça
c'était autre chose c'était pas sa
famille c'était un autre rapport
alors Picasso meurt à l'âge de 92 ans
deux jours plus tard votre grand frère
pardon Pablito
il va devant les grilles de la maison il
est renvoyé et on l'accepte pas qui
rentre dans cette maison alors que son
grand-père venait de mourir il absorbe
de l'eau de javel et ce qui est terrible
c'est que faute d'argent on peut pas
l'emmener dans un hôpital à Marseille et
il agonise pendant 90 jours pendant
trois mois à l'hôpital de La Fontonne à
Antibes
et on n'a pas pu le sauver je pense
qu'on aurait pas pu le sauver davantage
mais on a même pas pu tenter cette
chance alors il vous dit un truc d'une
grande beauté il vous dit c'est un peu
pour vous qui s'est tué d'une certaine
façon et vous dites désormais il
s'occupe de toi désormais ils sauront
que tu existes donc d'une certaine façon
il suit il s'y molle un peu il pensait
qu'à travers ce genre d'existence oui je
pense il pensait qu'à travers ce geste
il allait faire réagir ma famille et il
était bien loin du compte parce que
personne n'a bougé
et quand votre père vient le voir à la
Fontonne il refuse de le voir oui parce
qu'il était malade déjà depuis deux mois
et bon je pense qu'il sentait qu'il
allait bientôt mourir et il n'avait plus
envie de cette visite il pensait que
c'était trop tard donc il meurt à 24 ans
après trois mois d'agonie et votre mère
vous dit à ce moment là c'est toi qui
aurait dû mourir pas lui oui je
comprends que vous avez fait 14 ans
analyse
même à la limite je trouve que c'est
déjà bien d'en faire vous en êtes
aujourd'hui alors ensuite il y a la
bataille sur l'héritage beaucoup
d'argent 6 milliards de francs
c'est rien du tout similaire de francs
bataille juridique enfin ce qui me
concerne il n'y a pas eu tellement de
batailles juridiques puisque j'ai été
une héritière directe
non je crois que ça a duré 7-8 ans pour
une succession comme celle-là c'était
normal non vous avez droit à un
cinquième et les autres petits enfants
Les illégitimes ils ont droit à un
dixième
à peu près comme ça
vous retrouvez avec beaucoup d'argent
oui je me trouve dans une situation
assez contrastée mais c'est vrai qu'à
cette époque j'en avais pas tellement
envie puisque je n'en avais pas eu
pendant tant d'années et c'était un peu
dénué de sens dans la mesure mon frère
et mon père était mort je voyais
vraiment l'utilité à ce moment-là de
cette argent à votre mère oui oui vous
avez de l'argent à des gens qui ont été
sympas avec vous pendant toutes ces
années c'est gentil c'est l'échange
au début vous achetez une moto une
Porsche une Ferrari je vous rendez
compte que c'est des conneries quand
même non c'est pas des conneries c'est
sympa j'aime j'aime beaucoup conduire
mais bon j'avais des choses à vivre
j'essayais de les vivre puis après je me
suis rendu compte que c'était pas tout
et rapidement donc vous faites une
fondation pour des orphelins au Vietnam
donc vous occupez vous adoptez trois
enfants vietnamien aussi
voilà c'est bien
c'est un côté positif de la vie je pense
que c'est bien d'avoir rendu à des
enfants ce que moi je n'ai pas eu
lorsque j'étais enfant et puis eux me
donne beaucoup donc c'est un bon échange
vous avez pensé que vous avez racheté
votre grand-père une certaine façon
un plan humain je pense que j'ai
beaucoup
compris
vous avez vu des enfants biologiques je
dirais mais vous avez aussi des enfants
adoptés
alors bon quand il y a l'histoire de
Citroën qui rachète le nom de Picasso
vous ça vous effondré comment des gens
dans tellement d'argent peuvent-ils
avant de leur nom
pour de l'argent mais moi je l'ai appris
par la presse comme tout le monde j'ai
j'ai fait un procès à ma famille et j'ai
été déboutée parce que j'étais la seule
à vouloir annuler ce contrat donc voilà
maintenant aujourd'hui je suis devant un
fait accompli bon mais je ne peux plus
rien faire mais au moins j'ai essayé de
faire quelque chose je trouve ça triste
votre vie de femme n'a pas été facile au
milieu de tout ça non non je crois que
c'est pas facile d'avoir un nom aussi
lourd d'être héritière et bon et d'être
comprise à plein d'endroits enfin c'est
la vie la fortune isole
que mes deux grands enfants moi-même et
ça n'a pas d'intérêt pour les autres
donc j'ai laissé un blanc
[Musique]
avec Louis Valentin c'est chez de Noël
vous n'échapperez pas à une courte
interview mais très facile rassurez-vous
comme vous êtes la petite fille de
Picasso c'est l'interview couleur c'est
normal
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui vous rend vers l'orage
quand une personne que j'aime me fait
attendre
qu'est-ce qui vous rendrai pas qu'est-ce
qui vous rend rouge dehors
quand on humilie une personne dans ma
présence
quand je me trouve nez à nez avec une
souris ah bon
et rose de bonheur
remporte des compétitions épiques
qu'est-ce qui vous fait rire jaune quand
mes enfants asiatiques jouent au
football dans mes salons où il y a des
poteries de mon grand-père
[Musique]
c'est chez de Noël
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais vous laisser filer Marina merci
d'être venu en tous les cas et d'avoir
réservé votre première télévision pour
nous et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu